these gentleman's bumping mics can be
checked out right now available for
streaming on Netflix bumping mics with
Jeffrey Jeffrey Ross and Dave Attell
good to see you Jeff right buddy David
tell how are you boys we're good you
traveled out aren't you
you look like two traveled out
individual Dave doesn't like to get a
hotel room so he wears all this clothes
at the same time that's not a bad
sufficient Dave yeah it's good that is
good yeah you know I'm like a you know I
like to think that the streets are my
home you know it sounds like a
Springsteen song out I know like being
homeless
what type of flyer are you Dave yeah you
have pet peeves in the air well I don't
like to brag but I've been bumped up to
Economy Plus the legroom does take a lot
of the mean out of the flight I like a
window seat okay you know I will do an
aisle the middle seat they'll look at
these shoulders come on is that fair to
anybody no I know exactly so Jeff now
Jeff I think is a classier traveler all
the way through he likes it he likes a
little bit better
what how do you go sometimes to save
money when we're on tour I get a
first-class seat and then I stuffed
David in the overhead on the return I
get the overhead and he gets the seat
well you know what they say rich there's
no good or bad seat on a mega bus we did
this whole tour we did a whole bunch of
dates and then we got to our taping
that's in New York at the end of our
tour and we just kind of stopped and
took a break we'd like it to be very
special okay and we're very choosy about
what cities we go to we only go to our
very favorite places and those aren't
yeah well Vegas we went but that was a
little cuz Jeff handled the travel there
and I was a little upset what happened I
wanted to stay at the hotel New York New
York but it was sold out so I booked us
at Newark Newark yeah not the best
what's the decor like there at Newark
Newark
authentic first of all they wake you up
with a car alarm I think there was a
shopping cart in the pool
yeah and what you did in the lobby
should be outlawed okay yeah I think it
was as a matter of fact but the fun of
the tour is since we both toured
separately you know this guy is the
roastmaster he's got a million different
things going on project but when we're
together it's always good to be with
another fun comic who you can hang with
sure but because we're older now it's
like there's no party really we just go
eat you know go out to eat and it's like
I'm gonna roll elaborate you've been to
a casino the steak house you know we
really go nuts there so that's where you
really let it all hang out really the
last night we we went out for a big
dinner last channel right you said yeah
we gotta celebrate
[Music]
who is it who is it look at this guy
over here I mean come on
look at him he looks like you runs a
gift shop at a planetarium what did you
first meet each other how long somewhere
somewhere in between Grenada and now
probably in the in the 90s you know like
I've been due coming longer than him but
you know much longer a couple years
longer but you know the cool of it is
like basically especially back east is
that you know when the comics were all
in town we don't want to hang out and
like they're very cool like you know
like if I was on stage I'd bring Jeff up
and then we started riffing and stuff
like that and like you know you know
comedy really well I assume the audience
gets it that like you do you know this
there's your material and then there's
the riffing and there's crowd work and
all those different things so what's
cool is that Jeff can do all three and
when we mesh it together it becomes like
its own entity
it becomes like its own thing and I
think that's what you get to see in the
bumping mic thing and the real tip of
the hat goes to the director Andrew who
just really captured both on and off
these stage stuff that we do did you see
the jinx on HBO yeah that's I was about
to say that name sounds familiar he
directed the jinx on HBO so it's you two
guys in a serial murder who's been
lurking on unaccountably murder the
audience every night but to answer your
question your original question Dave and
I met at the date was hosting the open
mics when I was just starting yes he was
already the best comic in the open mic
scene and I said that's the guy when he
makes that we're all gonna make it
that's where you guys first met Matt
like that thank you for the emptiest of
compliments like I was in the open mic
muck and then I was like that is a gem
right there that's I really am our class
the Comets are too good to me I don't
see any of this like you know a lot of
comments coming through specially in LA
the younger guys they're like whoa dude
you know I grew up watching you look on
the insomniac show and the stand-up and
all that kind of stuff right I feel like
I'm right I'm always like that the same
thing I'm like trying to think of the
next joke I'm trying to think of the
next bit and like that never ends no
matter how far along you get and
especially in LA you know what you see
like Joe Rogan and Ali Wan they go out
every night and they're working on the
material too it's like really like the
crowds here are really really lucky if
they can see great comics you know
pretty much work on new material that's
pretty exciting you know and when Jeff
and I come by you know we never know
what's gonna happen either and I think
you know for every miss there's like two
hits so that's cool you know if we were
team I don't know about that but I feel
like it's just it's not even a show what
we do rich it's like a party on stage
yeah we'll have celebrities but we'll
also have our friends comics that aren't
famous comics that are wildly famous
right all sort of mixed into one show
you tell some of the people that were on
or on our thing come on Jeff drop some
names all right
we had a Paul Rudd Michael list the
coolest he got wasted on our show but
even that's how great Paul Rudd is even
him he's charming to begin with but even
like 10 tequila
and he's more charming can you imagine
now I can't imagine I can't I can't
believe well with him you can cuz I mean
you know he doesn't age he's like riding
a unicorn bareback I mean it is better
I'm trying to imagine yeah I'm trying to
walk through the visual right I know I
thought I captured it you know and I
think I'm kind of realizing what you're
talking about so rut is Paul's just
there right with his wife and friends
yes at the show and then states for the
Late Show okay yeah then I'm just like
hey Paul rugs here and you want to come
onstage and next thing you know we have
a two-minute blast with him Jevon knows
everybody he really is like telling you
I met Jeff Ross 2001 I heard it's a true
story let's take a look back at them
there was no camera on the streets of
New York just mad like a random yes at a
party I think it's a mutual friend John
Mosley I think was his birthday party
and I walked up to you you had no idea
what the hell I was which is very it's
it's oh it's okay Jeff I recognized you
you were like
at the end of SportsCenter they did be
like the guy way here that guy correct
and I walked up to you and I said that
the Bea Arthur joke that you told at the
Jerry Stiller roast the most amazing
joke of all time thank you and then
that's what you said and then you asked
me if I had a tuxedo and I'm like what
the hell is that
what is that code it's strange but then
you immediately followed up say that you
were having a Rolex you know you're
wearing a mask here at some weird party
yes like exactly was an important moment
in our friendship because it was right
after 9/11 and you said we're doing a
roast for Hugh Hefner do you want to
come right and I'm like are you kidding
me
yeah a thousand percent so lo and behold
a few days later I'm in a tux at the
very very end of the dais next to
frankie malcolm in the middle' muse and
the amazing Kreskin really very less I
was in the second alas it was really one
of the most amazing nights and that's
when we've been friends ever since we
raised a lot of money for the twin tower
fund that night so shout out it was a
maze you after wherever you are for
going through it that show it was an
amazing night we're doing the benefit
coming up this week yeah that's right
tomorrow night we're doing something at
the Fonda Theatre for the firefighters
fight who fought the wildfires here in
California you guys yeah good for you
guys Dave Attell and Jeffrey Ross here
on the Rich Eisen show have you are you
a sports fan and all David so I really
look like you know no you never know
that you just seventh care of me to a
Knicks game I'm assuming or no I did
kettlebells you know because you can
smoke while you do it
oh that's that's how you stay healthy
that's how I consider this but yeah I
I'm not really a big sport guy I used to
bet on the games but now you know I
would be more adult so I don't do that
okay yeah I know you've done some roasts
of who've you roasted I just had some
great athletes from Boomer Esiason
to Emmitt Smith Jack didn't you Russia
Shaq's putted many of my rows he's got
the best sense of humor ever mm-hmm the
first time I met Shaq I said you know
there's a lot of really like provocative
jokes here I didn't know him very well
this was a long time ago I didn't quite
have the rep rate that I have now and I
said Shaq I had some pretty crazy jokes
but I didn't want him to get mad a lot
of athletes don't are thin skin they're
not used to being taken down by just
some schmuck like me and I and I said
you'd be able to handle it and Shaq said
no one ever asked me to hold back on a
basketball court I would never ask you
to hold back at a roast no kidding
that's a champion that is I haven't
talked since
man that's great so uh who else you can
I say one thing about Jeff he is
fearless he is a he like I'm like always
up with a filter like I don't know if we
say above but he always runs towards it
and I really do appreciate that and in
these times that is you know it takes it
takes a pair you know and I really think
that that's one of Jeff's gifts instead
he both in the Rose on this thing and
then just I think you know whatever he
does he really throws all in on it so
I'm really lucky to be working with him
this is neat and and Dave to me is my
funniest comment is the funniest comic
in the world so if you watch bumping
mics you'll see it's basically me trying
to keep up with Dave for three episodes
right I'm fire and and do we want to
break news on how you guys are gonna
host the Oscars now or do we last joke
what are you nuts
it would be pretty great you they would
not be able to handle it I couldn't even
host a hot dog eating contest do I get
to show off my long snapping tonight you
get to shot yeah you got that football
yeah right there who do i cani snap it
to you you could if you want really yeah
from the green to here he played
football in high school do you know I
haven't done my long snaps in a while
but for some reason when you own it were
you a long snapper I was on the center
were you really yeah Jonathan Dayton
Regional High School Bulldogs Wow
Oh in 16 come on we never won a game
team for three years we never won a game
Jeffrey Ross with a center on a losing
team that never won for three straight
years ever blue snap no not once really
give you never misses snap even right
now brother that's the way you do
actually you know what let's go to break
yeah let's see we'll do it on television
on their locker a whole bunch of people
can see it yeah all right Dave Attell
and Jeffrey Ross here on the Rich Eisen
show go check out bump and mics on on
Netflix available for streaming right
now right now we've got all three part
series good to have you guys you got
right back at you Dave Attell and
Jeffrey Ross when we
come back on the television side of
things Jeffrey Ross is gonna long snap
I've never said those words before okay
Jeff Ross you were the center on what
team we're the centers on the Bulldogs
Jonathan Dayton Regional High School
shout-out to the bulldog that's right
and they want how many games we zero
okay Bri when was the last time you
actually long snap to football 1984 okay
you might be a little rusty no okay and
the fact that we have expensive
equipment and monitors around us we
should not be concerned at all be
worried man I've never missed a snap in
three seconds it's only I quit for the
fourth season Dave Attell with a Rich
Eisen show Calloway bag yeah will you
provide a D will you provide the
commentary sure okay okay in the right
spot what do you what was your what was
your uh what was your number for the
back yeah what was your number 50 okay
number 50 go ahead mother
Jeff lipschultz Lipshutz whoo all right
here we go
snap master general this is a great
number 50 about the snap
can I say it yeah the real hero here was
flex Jean one more time 34 I'll put
money on this one
here we go because I just want to see
your ass one this is going right through
an $8,000 Mon oh here we go alright
number 50 Jeff coming in for the second
snap all right there's a lot of oh nice
one more all right never left okay here
we go great Jeff Jeff lipschultz why did
you give up by the way I love the hike
I'm calling hi can I see the hike before
it here we go this is awesome this good
content Dave this is great this is what
people are tuning out for I mean aim for
nice huh boom I mean that got perfect I
see some hustle out there good game you
guys crazy
that's your first win on the football
bumping mics on my grace hydrate
available for streaming right now good
job Dave Attell there go
no you taking the club's taking the
club's the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience